يومكم واهلا بكم في هذه الساعه الاخباريه
من العربيه والتي نخصص جلها لتغطيه
التطورات في السودان ونبداها بالعناوين
تجدد الاشتباكات في اندرمان والشرطه تدفع
بتعزيزات امنيه لتامين الاحياء لمواجهه
الانفلات الامنيه
منذ صباح يوم 15 وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى
الصحه السودانيه تقول ان عشرات المستشفيات
خرجت عن الخدمه منذ بدء الاشتباكات وتدعو
لفتح ممرات انسانيه
مع استمرار الاقتتال منظمات دوليه ترصد
نزوحها نحو نصف مليون سوداني منذ بدء
الاشتباكات
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
مقتل عسكريا سوري واصابه سبعه اخرين في
غارات اسرائيليه على مطار حلب الدوري
[موسيقى]
رغم الهدنه المعلنه بين الجيش ودعم السريع
تجددت الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله صباح
اليوم في مدن سودانيه ابرزها اندرمان ومع
تفاقم الاوضاع الطبيه دعت وزاره الصحه
لفتح ممرات امنه للاغاثه الانسانيه
للمتضررين لم يتوقف الامر عند هذا الحد
حيث طر السودانيون الى النزوح هربا من
الاقتتال الدائر حيث قدرت اخر الاحصاءات
نزوح نحو النصف مليون شخص منذ بدء
الاشتباكات
ره
في زياده واي حاجه زايده لازم انا اشتغل
لي في ساعتين ثلاثه وقفل لانه البلد ما
امنه
بقى صعب
تخاطر بنفسه يحاول يستغل القواد ما حبابه
والخوف ما منه فائده
[موسيقى]
في التفاصيل فدى مراسل العربيه في السودان
عن سماع يدويه اسلحه ثقيله للشبكات بين
قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
في منطقه المهندسين حيث حلق طيران الجيش
السوداني في مدن الخرطوم الثلاث واستهدف
مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع اكد المراسل على
استمرار للشبكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم في
منطقه كافوري بالخرطوم بحري فيما شن طيران
الجيش السوداني قصفا جويا في ولايه شرق
النيل بحسب المراسل ياتي ذلك في وقت اعلنت
سلطات الطيران المدني السوداني تمديد
اغلاق المجال الجوي باستثناء طائرات
الاجلاء والمساعدات
هذا واظهرت الصور تحليقا للطائرات الحربيه
التابعه للجيش في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
حيث استهدفت مواقع وتمركزات لقوات الدعم
السريعه
[تصفيق]
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت
الجيش السوداني بتسبب في مقتل وجرح
العشرات من المواطنين بعد قصف مستشفى شرقا
للطيران الحربي اوضحت قواته دعم السريع
على تويتر ان القصف بالطيران شمل مستشفى
شرق النيل الى جانب قصف عدد من المصانع
بالمنطقه الصناعيه بحري وعدد من المنشات
المدنيه والطبيه والعسكريه
هذا واظهرت الصور في مدينه ود مدني بولايه
الجزيره وسط البلاد قيامه متطوعين
بمحاولات تامين الطعام والماوى لالاف
الفارينه من الشبكات
الناس لازم تهدا يشوفوا طريقه انه يحلوا
الموضوع ده لو ما قدروا يحلوا الموضوع ده
انا بتطلب من الامم المتحده تتدخل تشوف
امري لاحمتي
[موسيقى]
وفي محاولات لمواجهه حاله الانفلات
المستمره جراء الاشتباكات اعلنت الشرطه
السودانيه الدفع بتعزيزات امنيه لتامين
الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه والاحياء كما
اشارت الشرطه الى قيامها بحملات خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه في عدد من مناطق
جنوب الخرطوم بمشاركه وتنسيق امنيه مشترك
مع القوات المسلحه
نذهب الى الخرطوم بحري ومعنى هناك الصحفي
محمد اسحاق عثمان محمد مرحبا بك معنا في
سياق هذه التغطيه هل مازال الهدوء الحذر
هو سيد الموقف في الخرطوم بحري ام حصلت
خروقات
لازال الهدوء الحذر يسيطر على المكان ولكن
الحظ الان تحليق هذه الطائرات من جديد في
سم
الخرطوم بحري او في شمال بحري بالتحديد
منطقه جسر الحلفايه وكل هذه المناطق التي
تجاورها دادين هذه المنطقه تشهد منذ قبل
قليل عمليات تمشيط ايضا من قبل الجيش كما
تحدث الجيش ربما الساعات القادمه تشهد
تحولا واضحا لبسنا ذلك من خلال بعض
المصادر الذين اكدوا عزم الجيش في الساعات
القادمه على تغيير هذه الصوره تماما من
خلال هذه العمليات القويه والموجعه التي
يقوم بها الجيش منذ ليله البارحه الان
هدوء لا الحظ وحركه الحافلات السفريه ما
بين
الولاده التي تتمركز امامي في هذه اللحظات
لاخذ الذين يودون المقابله الى خارج ولايه
الخرطوم هدوء حظر يا محمد ورغم انك تسمع
يعني من هنا وهناك طائرات حربيه لاصوات
لطائرات ما طبيعه التعزيزات الامنيه التي
اعلنت الشرطه عن نشهر التامين الاحياء
بمناطق عده في الخرطوم ومنها الخرطوم بحري
نعم هذه هي واحده من الاشكالات لطالما
طالب المواطنون هنا بضروره تدخل الشرطه
التي دفعت بتعزيزات بمقوى الاحتياطي
المركزي هذه القوه المتخصصه الشبهي اقرب
بطبيعه تركيبتها وتكوينها كما تعلمين هي
اقرب للجيش هذه القوات نزلت وقامت بتامين
بعض المنافق ولكن يبدو بان العدد الذي نزل
كان قيده كافي بدليل اننا شاهدنا ايضا
مزيد بالعمليات السلب والنعم خصوصا في هذه
المنطقه التي انا متواجد فيها بالقرب من
جسر الحلفايه ليلا تشهد عمليات
للسلب والنهب ربما تصل الى مرحله القتل
وهم يحملون هذه الاسلحه البيضاء التي
يحتاجون من خلالها على الماره الذين
يخرجون احيانا في بعض فترات المساء لجلب
بعض الادويه او لاحضار بعض الماء لان
الماء ايضا هنا فيه اشكاليه ولكن هذه
الاصابات تتعرض لهم بصوره مباشره هذا يعني
خلق نوعا من الازعاج والخوف لدى مواطنين
هذه المنطقه شمال بحري محمد طالما تحدثنا
من الخرطوم بحرياب جسر الحلفايه كان بؤره
الاشتباكات وهو يربط الخرطوم بحري بام
درمان هل من تفاصيل معلومات جديده حول هذا
الجسر الحوالي
نعم هذا الجيش ربما عاده الحياه فيه من
يومين الى طبيعتها بعد ان شهد احداث داميه
كانت ما بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
التي حاولت استماتها ان تسيطر على هذا
الجسر لاهميته لان هذا للمعلوميه واحد من
الجسور الذي يقع في اقصى شمال الخرطوم
ويربط كذلك ما قلت مع مدينه بحري ويمكن
استقلاله الى حتى الوصول الى منطقه وادي
سيدنا التي من خلالها يتم اجراء الرعاه
الاجانب اذا كان الدعم السريع سيطره على
هذا الجسر جسر الحلفايه كان يمكن ان يحدث
ربطه واضحه لانهم يسيطرون على جسر الشنبات
وبسيطرتهم على جسر الحلفايه يكونوا قد
عملوا على قنط او احكام السيطره على منطقه
شمال بحري التي تقع فيها ايضا مصفاه
الجيلي التي تمد ولايه الخرطوم بالوقود
والمحروقات
طيب محمد مبادرات التهدئه عموما هل انعكست
على وضع الناس هل لمست انت محمد الانسان
قبل محمد الصحفي ان المواطنين يشعرون
بالاطمئنان اكثر شمال الخرطوم لمزاوله
اعمالهم
نعم
بالفعل كما ذكرتي علي الان خرج الناس الى
الشوارع بداوا ايضا هم يمارسون حياته بل
يوميا تعلمين نادين بان القالبيه هنا ايضا
يعتمدون على كما نقول الارزاق اليوميه
البسيطه يبيعونه يشترون في هذه الاسواق
ليس كل الناس هنا يعملون في وظائف حكوميه
هناك طبقات عماليه تعمل وتعتمد على رزقها
اليومي هؤلاء كانوا اكثر سعاده بمساله
الهدنه وتجديد الهدنه اراهما الان قد
اصطفوا وارتصوا على جوانب جسر الحلفايه
يحاولون ان يسترزقون من خلال هذه المساحات
تعلمين بانهم عمال يعملون في مجالات
مختلفه سواء كانت سباكه او الكهرباء او
هذه ال ال القضايا او الشقالات اللي يمكن
ان نطلق عليها فقيره
انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه الاحاطه
من الخرطوم بحريه الصحفي محمد اسحاق عثمان
في محاوله لحلحله الازمه الراهنه التقى
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري بالقاهره
مع السفير دفع الله الحاج علي المبعوث
الخاص لرئيس مجلس سياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان وجرى خلال اللقاء بحث
الازمه السودانيه والصراع المستمر منذ 18
يوما
قبل ذلك اقترح رئيس الوزراء السوداني
السابق عبد الله حمدوك اجراء حوار عاجل
بين الجيش ودعم السريع لتوفير الاساس لوقف
دائما لاطلاق النار بالاضافه الى اتفاق
على انشاء ممرات انسانيه دائمه واقترح
حمدوك ايضا اشراك المدنيين السودانيين في
مفاوضات شامله واستئناف العمليه السياسيه
مؤكدا على ان استمرار الحرب في السودان
وانتشارها في رقعه اوسع قد يضر العالم
باسره
وفي كلمتها امام المندوبين الدائمين في
الجامعه العربيه الذين عقدوا اجتماعا في
القاهره لبحث الاوضاع في السودان جدد فهد
الخمع لنائب المندوب الدائم للسعوديه لدى
الجامعه العربيه جدد دعوه بلاده لايقاف
المواجهات في السودان للحفاظ على حياه
المدنيين ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تجدد دعوتها لسرعه وقف العمليات العسكريه
والتحلي باقصى درجات ضبط النفس وتجنب
التصعيد وتقليم مصلحه الشعب السوداني
للحفاظ على مكتسباته ومقدراته والعوده الى
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يهدف الى الوصول
الى اعلان سياسي يحقق الامن والاستقرار
للسودان وشعبه الشقيق
وتؤكد المملكه على اهميه الالتزام بالهدنه
القائمه وحمايه المدنيين والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه وتوفير الممرات الامنه
للعاملين في المجال الانساني كما تؤكد
المملكه على ضروره العمل على تيسير وتامين
عمليات الاجلاء للمدنيين
في السياق قال محمد مصطفى عرفي مندوب مصر
الدائم لدى الجامعه العربيه واكد على
ضروره وقف اطلاق نار فورا في السودان
اننا نؤكد من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس على
ضروره الوقف الفوري غير المشروط للعنف
واتاحه الفرصه كامله لانجاح جهود التسويه
وجعلها تؤتي ثمارها في القريب العاجل
ونحذر من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس من ان
المساس بالمدنيين بالسودان واستهداف
منشاتهم لا سيما الطبيه منها هو امر خطير
للغايه ويمثل انتهاكا واضحا وسافرا
للقانون الدولي والقانون الدولي الانساني
من جانبي اكد امجد العضايا لمندوب الاردن
لدى الجامعه العربيه ان كافه الاطراف
بالسودان عليها التحلي بالمسؤوليه مشددا
على ضروره ايجاد حل داخليا سودني يعكس
تطلعات السودانيين بعيدا عن اي تدخلات
خارجيه ونؤكد ضروره تحلي كافه الاطراف
بروح المسؤوليه الوطنيه واعلاء المصالح
العليا للسوداني وشعبه الشقيق فوق اي
اعتبار اخر حقنا لدماء السودانيين وتفاديا
لقتال بين ابناء الشعب الواحد لن يكون
المنتصر فيها الا خاسرا فالقاتل والمقتول
اخوه والثمن المدفوع امن واستقرار ومنعت
السوداني واستقلاله ووحدته ووحدته ودماء
ابنائه ونؤكد ان اي حل للازمه الراهنه
لابد ان يكون حلا داخليا سودانيا يعكس
اراده وتطلعات الشعب السوداني الشقيق
بعيدا عن اي ت دخلات خارجيه
هذا وكانت لكاميرا العربيه جوله مع
المواطنين السودانيين في بعض احياء
الخرطوم للوقوف على مدى تاثير واقع
للشبكات والمعارك على حياتهم نتابع
والله الواحد كان مواطن سوداني يعني
بيتالم
قلم شديد جدا جدا الوضع الحاطي في البلد
وانا يعني ما اقدر اقول يعني اقوم اقول
انه البلد فيها
نحن ما حنقول ولا حنقول علان نحن الحصه
وطن الحصه نحن مع الجيش مع البرهان في
الان بعد داخل المحاسبه ممكن تجي نحن
بنعاني من ترده خدمات من الثوره لحد الان
وجهت الحرب بنهايه الخدمات تماما غياب
تامل الجيش وغياب تام للامن وحتحصل اكثر
من كذا نحن مع البيجي يسلحنا هنا في
الاحياء بنجيب معهم الوضع كله جايط والحمد
لله الظروف ذي ما شايفه يعني الشوارع
فاضيه كيف
ما في ناس ما في محلات فاتحه
يعني حتى احنا عشان نطلع نشتغل به البنزين
مشكله بالنسبه لينا
نذهب الى الخرطوم معنا هناك اللواء ركن
دكتور محمد خليل الصائم استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه والدراسات الاستراتيجيه دكتور
محمد اهلا بك معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه ما
فرص نجاح مبادرات التهدئه والتحركات
العربيه والدوليه منها لجعل الطرفين
العسكريين المتحاربين يوقفاء المعارك
نهائيا اقله
طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم التحيه لكم
والتحيه لكل المشاهدين الكرام
فرص يعني الناس ترحب بوقف اطلاق النار
ولكن هذه قوه متمرده على القوات المسلحه
يجب ان كان هنالك وقف لاطلاق النار يجب ان
يتم وقف اطلاق النار بشروط القوات المسلحه
على ان تخرج هذه العناصر الدعم السريع من
كافه احياء الخرطوم لان كافه احياء
الخرطوم هي ليست مسارح للعمليات هي سكن
لكل المواطنين هي خدمات للمياه وقدمات
للصحه وخدمات الكهرباء كل المناطق دي الان
متواجدين فيها عناصر من الدعم السريع يخرج
بشروط القوات المسلحه اذا كانت هنالك
تهدئه يجب ان تخرج القوه المتمرده تحكم
صوت العقل الى ان اذا كانت هي قوه
ترى انها قوه تتبع للقوات المسلحه يجب ان
تخضع لشروط القوات المسلحه والا سوف تستمر
القوات المسلحه في حجم هذا الموقف طيب لكن
لواء ركن يعني بالحديث عن الشروط هل يمكن
ان يقبل الطرفان هكذا ان يخريا ساحه
المعارك بعد كل ما جرى طوال ثلاثه اسابيع
بدون ان يحصل على دور واضح في العمليه
السياسيه في مستقبل السودان
ليس الطرفان انا اعني طرف القوات المسلحه
هي كيان الدوله هي ليست كان القوات
المسلحه ليست منتشره في احياء الخرطوم
الدعم السريع هو الذي كان ينتشر في 72
موقع في الخرطوم وهي مواقع مدنيه وليست
عسكريه وكانوا يسيطر من ضمنها يسيطر
محيط القصر الجمهوري وخلافه وكان برضا
القوات المسلحه ولكن لما بدا الصراع من
جانب الدعم السريع انتشرت هذه القوات داخل
الاحياء وفي مناطق الخدمات وفي مناطق
الامداد بالمياه وفي مناطق الكهرباء يجب
اخراج هذه القوات اولا
محمد هذا واقع لا يمكن انكاره لا يمكن نفي
وجود عدد كبير من هذه القوات التي تتبع
للدعم السريع
نعم يجب ان تضع السلاح ارضا بدايه لانها
قوه تمردت على القوات المسلحه
تبع السلاح ارضا ثم بعد ذلك يتم وقف اطلاق
النار وايضا انا احب ان اؤكد انه نحن
دعاه سلام الابناء من الدعم السريع
استقاره الصين معظمهم استخاره السن هم
يعني ضحايا لهذه الحرب ومات عدد منهم كثير
جدا عشرات الالاف قتل منهم وهذا يعني
اهدار لطاقات الشباب السودانيه يجب ان
القوه التي تمردت على القوات المسلحه ان
تحكم صوت عقل وتوقف هذه الحرب وتبعث سلاح
ارضا لتست
مع وتستمع
للقوات خرجت من رحمها
الدكتور محمد اليوم من بيده العصا السحريه
ليعيد الوضع اقل قبل الخامس عشر من ابريل
ليس هنالك شخص بيده العصا السحريه هنالك
الصراع دائره الان بين قوات متمرده على
القوات المسلحه والقوات المسلحه السودانيه
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه في تقدير قادر
على حتم هذا الموقف
ايا كان الناس تنظر الى بنظره استراتيجيه
الى النصفين الفارق من الكوب
والمكثر لو كان بقدرتها ان تحسم لحسمته في
من قبل ما رايه والله اقول لك حاجه لو كان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتنتشر قوات
على على مساحه هذه
الماكولات الخرطوم لا تستطيع ان تخرجها
الا بالعمل الذي تعمل فيه القوات المسلحه
الان لو كانت القوات المسلحه الامريكيه
هذه قوات انتشرت على مدى على مساحه ولايه
الخرطوم وبين المنازل وهي مقسمه للجيوب
انا اكتفي معك واشكرك جزيل الشكر من
الخطوبه دكتور محمد خليل الصائم استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اما الان فنذهب معكم الى اقليم دارفور
ومعنا من هناك الصحفي صالح ابو علامه اهلا
بك صالح معنا حتى هذه الساعه جديد
المعطيات التي رصدتموها في اقليم دارفور
نبدا من جنوب دارفور مدينه نيالا
يبدو صالح هل تسمعني مرحبا يعني سنحاول
نتاكد بان الصوت واضح ولا يتقطع من عندك
تمام تفضل
نعم انا اسمعك جيدا
من جنوب دارفور مدينه مدينه نيالا حيث
الو مرحبا صالح نحن نسمعك اكمل الفكره
يعني طرف اسرع وقع امس على وثيقه لوقف
العمل العدائيه هل تمثل ذلك على ارض
الواقع في اقليم دارفور
نعم
الثلاثه يوم من عمليه التهدئه هنا في جنوب
دارفور عدد
تدريجيا الان في افضل حالتها في جنوب
دارفور مدينه كما رصدنا وكما نشاهد الان
حركه في سوق نياله الكبير هنا في جنوب
دارفور اما في غرب دارفور فليله البارحه
تم التوقيع على وثيقه لوقف العدائيات بين
المجموعات السكانيه المتحاربه بين
المساليت والقبائل العربيه في غرب دارفورت
هذه الوثيقه احتوت على عده بنود من ضمنها
ايقاف العدائيات وفتح الطرقات داخل
الاحياء وبالاسواق وايضا منع التجمعات
داخل الاسواق وفتح الطرقات مع دوله ساد
لنقل الجرحى
للتواصل مع ساده المجاوره
لمدينه الجنينه
بغربي دارفور كما انه تم منع اطلاق اللعير
الناريه ومنع المظاهر العسكريه داخل
المدينه المتمثله في حمل الاسلحه وارتداء
الازياء العسكريه في مدينه الجنينه
بغربي دارفور
تمام هل من معلومات جديده حول مستشفى
الجنينه حيث افادت وزاره الصحه يعني يوم
امس بانه دمر واتلفت ممتلكاته
المستشفى حتى يعود للعمل يحتاج الى وقت
اطول حتى يباشر عمله لانه تم نهبه تماما
تم نهب الاجهزه تم نهر تم تدمير بنك الدم
تم تدمير جهاز الاشعه
الذي يحتاج اليه الجرحى في هذه الايام
كثيرا المستشفى غير قادر على العمل ابدا
هنالك مراكز صحيه تم يعني تشغيلها بجهود
شبابيه جهود اهليه في احياء مدينه الجنينه
منها المركز
الخاصه وايضا هنالك مراكز اخرى يجري الان
العمل لتشغيلها بالجهود الشبابيه
والشعبيه الوضع الصحي متردي في الجنينه
ويحتاج
لتدخل كبير يحتاج للمنظمات يحتاج لتدخل
للجهود الرسميه حتى يعود للعمل في وقت
قريب يعني الوضع الانساني ايضا هنالك
انقطاع تام للمياه بعض الاحياء فقط عادت
اليها المياه مثل 13
وايضا اماكن اخرى لكن الوضع
الاحياء
كثيره لا توجد فيها مياه ولا توجد ولا
يوجد فيها ايضا كهرباء حتى هذه
اللحظه التحديات التي تواجه الوثيقه التي
تم التوقيع عليها ليله البارحه هي كيفيه
تنفيذ هذه الوثيقه
وجعلها على ارض الواقع هنالك قيادات اهليه
القيادات التي توسطت بين المجموعات
السكانيه المتحاربه تسعى جاهده لتطبيق هذه
الوثيقه علما بان في الجنينه عدد كبير من
الوثائق تم التوقيع عليها ولكنها خرجت بعد
ذلك يامل الكثيرين بان توقع بان هذه
الوثيقه يعني تنزل على ارض الواقع وتمنع
التفلتات وتحسن من الوضع الانساني الموجود
هنا في الجنينه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
الاحاطه من اقليم دارفوره الصحفي صالح ابو
علامه
هذا واظهرت صور استهداف طيران للجيش
السوداني لاهداف وتمركزات تتبع لقوات دعم
السريعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي متابعه لتطورات الاوضاع الصحيه قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن ان تسعه وثلاثين
مستشفى خرجت عن الخدمه منذ بدء الاشتباكات
مؤكدا للعربيه ان قوات دعم السريع حولت
بعض المستشفيات لتقنات عسكريه عبد الرحمن
كان دعا الى فتح ممرات انسانيه لاغاثه
الضحايا مسلسلات التي توقفت على الخدمه
منذ صباح يوم 15 وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى
هذه المستشفيات هي في مناطق الاشتباكات
حتى تاريخ اليوم مناطق غير امنه هي
مستشفيات التي متاخمه لمناطق الاشتراك
شارع القصر وشارع
المطار والقياده والاذاعه ومركز ومركز
البحري
مقابل قال سكرتير نقابه اطباء السودان
عطيه عبد الله قال للعربيه ان كل
المستشفيات العامه في الخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل بسبب عدم توفر الوقود مشددا على ان
الحل الوحيد الوضع الانساني هو وقف القتال
حيث وصف الاوضاع الصحيه بالكارثيه
الاوضاع في الجنينه كارثيه للغايه نعم
النظام الصحي لازال يتهوى في كل لحظه وحين
بالامس عدد من المستويات خرجت خارج الخدمه
لانه لم نستطيع ايصال كوادر طبيه اليها
وبعض الاخر خرج من الخدمه لانقطاع الوقود
الجازلين وايضا هنالك يعني عدد من
الولايات تعاني من نقص في الاكسجين حتى في
ولايه الخرطوم
هذه العوامل مجتمعه وهو ما ظللنا ان نحذر
منه من اليوم الاول ستؤدي الى الى نتيجه
لا نتمناها ابدا وهي انهيار النظام الصحيه
نحن نتخوف ان يحدث مع يعني يحصل مع حدث
الجنينه في عدد من المدن وهو ما تخوف عنه
لذلك نحن مطالبه لطرفي الصراع الان هي
ايقاف هذه الحرب داخل الولايات الخرطوم
هنالك مستشفيات توقفت تماما لانه ما فيها
معينات طبيه
مع استمرار المواجهات بات النزوح هو الحل
امام الالاف من السودانيين هربا من
الاقتتال الدائر في هذه الاثناء كشفت
بيانات المنظمه الدوليه للهجره الى نزوح
اكثر من 334 الف شخص داخل السودان منذ بدء
الاشتباكات فيما افاد مسؤول بالامم
المتحده بعبور اكثر من مئه الف شخص لحدود
السودان الى دول مجاوره حتى الان مؤكدا ان
الامم المتحده بحاجه لواحد فاصله خمسه
مليار دولار لتلبيه الاحتياجات الانسانيه
في السودان لهذا العام
وفي متابعه لعمليات النزوح وعلى الحدود
المصريه السودانيه تستمر عمليات استقبال
السودانيين الفاريين من الاشتباكات في
بلادهم الى مصر اغلب القادمين ياتون من
خلال منفذ قسطل البري ومن بعده يصلون
لمدينه ابو سمبل عن طريق عبارات نهر النيل
احمد عثمان وتفاصيل في تقرير التالي
نحن الان امام المرسى النيلي لمدينه ابو
سمبل في انتظار العبارات النيليه القادمه
والتي يستقلها السودانيون القادمون عبر
منفذ قسطل البري في اصعب من كيل كونك تخلي
دارك
بدايه الحرب في المنازل انعطاع التيار
الكهربائي الميه ما فيش ما فيش ولا حاجه
وعلى الرغم من استمرار تدفق القادمين من
السودان الى مصر باعداد كبيره الا ان هناك
من يفضل استقلال نفس الحافلات للعوده الى
السودان حاليا السودان في ازمه
واهالي الخرطوم كلهم جايين الى مصر هذا
المكان يعد مكانا للراحه للقادمين
المرهقين من السودان قبل ان يستانفوا
رحلاتهم مره اخرى سواء الى اسوان او الى
القاهره وجدت تعاون طيب جدا حقيقه من
اخواننا المصريين كانهم اخواتنا يعني ومع
غروب الشمس تتوقف حركه العبارات النيليه
لينتظر الجميع سطوع شمس يوم جديد لكل من
يريد ان يذهب او ياتي الى الاراضي المصريه
من السودان احمد عثمان لقناتي العربيه
والحدث من مدينه ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
من جانبه قال رئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي ان تدفق العديد من السودانيين الى
مصر سيخلق صعوبات في البلاد الرئيس السيسي
اشار الى ان بلاده ستتاثر بشكل واضح بنزاع
في السودان في حال تدفق المزيد من
اللاجئين خاصه ان مصر تعاني من صعوبات
اقتصاديه في ظل الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كما اضاف ان مصر في الاصل
استقبلت حوالي تسعه ملايين لاجئ من
السودان وليبيا وسوريا واليمن ومن دول
اخرى
معنى مباشره من مرسى مدينه ابو سمبل مراسل
العربيه احمد عثمان احمد اهلا بك معنا في
سياق هذه التغطيه جديد المعطيات المتعلقه
بتدفق الاعداد من النازحين في الفتره
الاخيره وحتى الان
مرحبا نادين اهلا بك وبالساده المشاهدين
ربما اجعل الكاميرا تتحدث او تنقل اولا
هذا هو مشهد احدى العبارات النيليه
القادمه من منفذ قصته البري وعلى متنها
عدد من الحافلات والسيارات وعلتني الكثير
من السودانيين القادمين وايضا من المصريين
الذين تم عبورهم من منفذ قسطل البريه
بدايه اذا تحدثنا فان هناك استمرار لتدفق
الراجحيين الالاف من النازحين من السودان
عبر منفذي قسطل ومنفذ ارجين ربما في خلال
الايام الماضيه كانت تركيز اكثر على منفذ
قسطل الهدوء بدا واضحا على
منفذ ارجين اذا ما قرن بقسطل لسببين السبب
الاول بان هناك محاوله لتخفيف الضغط من
على منفذ ارجينا الذي كان محطه الانظار
خلال الايام الماضيه وايضا بحسب ما سمعنا
من بعض القادمين بان هناك صعوبه في وصول
الكثير منهم الى منفذ ارجين او السوداني
من مركز بالمركز ارجيل بسبب مضايقات في
الطرق وبالتالي كان هناك تفضيل من قبل
القادمين في الايام الماضيه للاتجاه
مباشره عبر وادي حلفا الى منفذ قسطنطن
للوصول الى هنا اذا تحدثنا عن الارقام
نادين احدث الارقام كانت منذ يومين ان
هناك 14,000 هذا الرقم مرشح للزياده هناك
ربما تفضيل بانه الذي يجوز ذكر او من
الصعوبه تحديد ارقام معينه بحسب تصريحات
لوزيره الهجره امس بانه لاحدى القنوات
بانه يعني هذه الارقام تتغير على مدار
الساعه ولكن هناك متابعه من قبل الجهات
المعدنيه المصريه بالنازحين والقادمين
وبردود الافعال على كافه الاصعده امنيا
واقتصاديا كما ذكرتي نادين التصريحات
الاخيره للرئيس السيسي لجريده اساهه
اليابانيه والتي تحدث فيها حول هذه النقطه
تحديدا
طب
احمد من تطورات الازمه من خلال تصريحات
الرئيس السيسي الاخيره وايضا هذه التحركات
يعني اليوم وزير الخارجيه يستقبل المبعوث
الخاص للبرهان
يعني هذه مصر تتعامل مع هذه الازمه من وفق
كل المعطيات المطلوبه المعطاه هناك
المتطورات الانسانيه فيما يتعلق بالنازحين
ولكن هناك ايضا يعني تعاطي مع الملف من
زوايا امنيه ومن زوايا سياسيه يعني
الموضوع السوداني بالنسبه لمصر يتعلق
بالامن القومي المصري هذا الخط المعروف
الخط اثنين والعشرين هذا الخط الحدودي كان
على مدار عقود ربما يعني الاكبر للهاربين
فيما يتعلق بالعناصر الارهابيه التي خرجت
خلال الاعوام الماضيه الجماعات الاسلاميه
التي نشطت خلال التسعينيات القرن الماضي
وبالتالي هناك تركيز شديد جدا على تامين
الحدود الجميع يؤكد بان فكره الحدود
البريه الطويله ما بين مصر والسودان هي
مساله امن قومي ومن ثم هناك يجب ان يكون
هناك تاكيد للتاكيد مصري وحذر مصري من
جميع الذين ياتون الى السودان بانهم ياتون
لظروف انسانيه ولا يكون هناك اي استغلال
او محاوله استغلال للمشهد الحالي في
السودان للتسلل الى مصر هناك من يربطون
بين مخاطر ما حدث على الحدود المصريه
الغربيه مع ليبيا في عام 2011 وتسلل بعض
العناصر القادمه من قبل الجماعات
الارهابيه هناك عبر الحدود المصريه فهناك
تركيش شديد بان لا يكون تكرار لهذا المشهد
مره اخرى من قبل الحدود الجنوبيه هذا فيما
يتعلق بالناحيه الامنيه فيما يتعلق
بالناحيه الاقتصاديه ايضا يعني هناك من
يرى بان مصر في الفتره الاخيره يعني تعاني
من ازمات اقتصاديه على تبعات الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وان مصر تستضيف بالفعل
ملايين سواء من سوريا ومن اليمن ومن ليبيا
ومن غيرها من الدول وبالتالي بان اي
استمراريه في الازمه المقبله فيما يتعلق
بالسودان يعني زياده ارقام النازحين
القادمين سيكون له تاثير سلبي على المشهد
الاقتصادي المصري وهذا ما يؤكد التصريحات
التي خرجت من قبل المسؤولين المصريين بدءا
من الرئيس السيسي او وزير الخارجيه سامح
شكري وغيره من المسؤولين بان مصر حريصه كل
الحرص على ان يكون هناك استمرار لوقف
اطلاق النار والانطلاق لمشهد سياسي جديد
بالتصالح ووقف نظيف الدماء للعوده مره
اخرى الى طاوله الحوار في اقرب وقت ممكن
شكرا جزيلا لك من مرسى مدينه ابو سمبل
مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان
ربنا يحفظكم ان شاء الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر منصورين ان
شاء الله الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
جاهزين
[تصفيق]
كنا نتابع معكم هذا الفيديو المتداول
لتفقد الفريق اول ركن ياسر السياده اسنان
التمركزات الجنود خلال المواجهات مع قوات
الدعم السريع نستكمل الاخبار هذه الساعه
قرر الامين العام للامم المتحده
في حالات الطوارئ ووكيل الامين العام
للشؤون الانسانيه
تقديم الاغاثه الفوريه لملايين الاشخاص
الذين انقلبت حياتهم راسا على عقب بسبب
القتال الدائر في السودان
قبل ذلك اكد المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده سيفان ديجري ان المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده للشؤون اللاجئين
تخطط لاستقبال اكثر من 800 الف شخص قد
يفيرون من القتال في السودان الى الدول
المجاوره
يدعم صندوق الامم المتحده للسكان الشركاء
على الارض بالرعايه الصحيه المنقذه للحياه
ومعدات الولاده الامنه تخطط المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
بالتشاور مع الحكومات والشركاء لاستقبال
اكثر من 800 الف شخص قد يفرون من القتال
في السودان الى الدول السبع المجاوره تؤكد
احدث الارقام من فرقنا على الارض ان 73
الف شخص قد وصلوا الى البلدان المجاوره
مما في ذلك اللاجئون السودانيون ولا سيما
من جنوب السودان
نزح ما يقرب من 20 الف لاجئ سوداني
اغلبيتهم من النساء والاطفال منهم من
يعاني من امراض تنفسيه خطيره غير ان ينسف
حذرت من البقاء في قريه كفرنت شاديه خوفا
من موسم الامطار المقبل
خطا نهايتها عصيه طريق اللجوء يطول وصلنا
وحدات الى تشاد لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقل عليهن عبء
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله
البيوت وقد قتلوا ثلاثه نفر اربعه كده
عشان كده
استقروا هنا على الحدود الارشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
20,000 لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه
كوفرون تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه
وضروره تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوامر
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحه عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
وفي تطورات عمليات الاجلاء قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها الجويه قامت
باجلائي اكثر من 200 شخص من الاراضي
السودانيه بناء على قرار الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين مضيفه ان اربع طائرات عسكريه قامت
بعمليات الاجلاء حيث شملت موظفي البعثه
دبلوماسيه الروسيه في السودان والمكاتب
التمثيليه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وعائلاتهم من مواطني روسيا وبلدان رابطه
دول مستقله وعدد من الدول الاجنبيه صديقه
في مشهد مؤثر لعمليه اجلاء نقل افراد من
البحريه السعوديه شابا من ذوي الاعاقه من
ميناء بورسودان الى سطح سفينه درعيه
المتجهه الى جده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العربيه الثانيه
باقي هنا
[موسيقى]
الله يحييك
افاد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
فيدن باتل بان بلاده نجحت في جاي اكثر من
الف مواطن امريكي من السودان عبر ثلاث
قوافل في وقت كان البيت الابيض قد اعلن
نشر طائراتان لمراقبه عمليات الاجلاء
ليس هناك اي عدد محدد نفصح عنه لاعداد
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين غادروا
السودان المواطنون الامريكيون هم من
يتخذون القرار بشان المغادره بحسب
اولوياتهم تواصلنا خلال هذه الازمه مع
اكثر من خمسه الاف مواطن امريكي مقيم في
السودان واجلينا الفا مواطن منهم عبر ثلاث
قوافل
كملت الخارجيه الامريكيه جهود السعوديه في
استقبال المواطنين الامريكيين وايضا
المساعده في عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
عموما
اود القول ان السعوديه لعبت دورا مهما ليس
فقط في استقبال مواطنينا لكن في دعم
الرباعيه وكانت حلقه وصل في الدفع بتمديد
هدنه الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف ان الواحد
يكون كله يعني قوه
بامان الناس كثيره هناك عندها مشاكل ما
قادره ما عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري ناس
كتير معلقه فنحمد الله سبحانه
لاهل المملكه على هذا الاستق
[موسيقى]
تستمر عمليات اجلاء رعايه الدول الاجنبيه
من شرق السودان حيث غادر اكثر من 16 الف
طالب اجلاء غادروا البلاد خلال الايام
الماضيه
عشره ايام مضت على اول عمليه اجلاء لرعايه
دول الاجنبيه من شرق السودان نحو مختلف
الدول العالم عبر ميناء بورسودان وعبر
مطهرها الدولي اكثر من 20 رحله بحريه تمت
حتى الان ونحو 45 رحله جويه من مطار
بورسودان الدولي تستمر عمليات الاجلاء دون
توقف غير ان اوضاع الرعايه السوريين
المطالبين بجلائهم تشكل استثناء هنا عم
نطلب من المروح نحن اي بلد
فيزا اربيل عراق مصر اي اي مكان ما حدا
سال علينا العيال في الشوارع النساء
الشباب مضى معه مصاري هاي ماده تصرف الحمد
لله الشعب السوداني ما هو مقصر ابدا لا من
اكل لا من ملبس لا من ماء
هذا الوضع اضبط الاخرى تشهدها المنافذ نحو
الخارج حيث يواجه السودانيون المقيمون في
عدد من الدول ظروف صعبه يقول كثير منهم ان
اوضاعهم لا تحتمل تاخر اجراءات مغادرتهم
للسودان نحن اننا زيارات يعني في ناس
واقفه دي مشكله
فبالناس تقول السلطات يا جماعه انه لو في
امكانيه توفر لنا بواخر نحن بحقنا بتذاكر
بنشتري كل السودانيين
مستطيعين انهم يدفعوا حق التذاكر بس ما
موجوده بواخر نحن كسودانيين مقيمين في
السعوديه نناشد السلطات السودانيه
والسلطات السعوديه انه يسرعوا في اجراءات
اجلانا من مدينه بورسودان الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لانه عندنا طلبه عندهم
جامعات وعندهم اسر
الشفقانين شديد ولازم يصلون باسرع وقت
للمواجهات المسلحه ارتدادات مختلفه يامل
كثيرون هنا الا تتمدد لتشمل قطاعات اخرى
نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
قالت صحيفه بريطانيه في تقرير لها ان
المعركه في السودان تغذيها قوه خارج حدوده
اشارت صحيفه الى ان معظم التقارير عن
السودان
ركزت على العاصمه الخرطوم بينما تمثل
الصحراء بين السودان وليبيا منطقه مهمه
ترسم صوره اوضحا خفايا النزاع
الصراع في السودان وصلت تاثيراته بالفعل
الى خارج حدوده ومساحته الجغرافيه في
الجانب الانساني نازحون ولاجئون الى دول
الجوار وايضا التاثير العسكري عابر لحدود
السودان بحسب تقرير لصحيفه جارديان
البريطانيه
التقرير قال ان حدود السودان تشهد حركه
قوافل شاحنات قادمه من ليبيا تنقل الوقود
من مصفاه بالقرب من مدينه الجوف الليبيه
بكميه تصل الى ما يعادل عشره الاف برميل
من النفط الليبي يوميا ويتم بيعها ثم
نقلها برا للسودان اضافه للوقود يتم تهريب
شحنات اخرى من الذخيره والاسلحه والادويه
للسودان لتغذيه النزاع هناك بينما تحصل
اطراف ليبيه على المقابل المادي جاردي
نقلت عن شهود عيان في مطار الجوف ان
امدادات تتضمن صواريخ كورنيت المضاده
للدبابات يتم نقلها جوا من الجوف الى
ولايه ومنها لعده ولايات سودانيه
الصحيفه نقلت عن خبراء قولهم ان تجاره
الحرب هذه ليست بالجديده هو انها قائمه
لمده عقد او اكثر الا ان تاثيرها لن يكون
كبيرا لدرجه قلب التوازن القائم على الارض
وشدد الخبراء على ان النزاع والاضطراب
المرافق له سيمهد ارضيه من اجل الاستفاده
سياسيا من قبل عدد من القوى الدوليه التي
ستحاول ايجاد موطئ قدم لها في السودان
بينما تحاول دول اخرى تجنب التهديد الذي
قد يشكله اي انهيار في السودان على
مصالحها الخاصه حسن جوليد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات